des bateaux amarrés est immobilisé
depuis maintenant 15 jours les employés
de la compagnie de transport maritime
vedette tropicales sont en grève
aucune rotation n'est effectué depuis le
19 mars dernier
et pourtant sur les quais comme ici aux
trois ilets les navettes sont attendues
grâce aux navets du coup on pouvait
aller à fort-de-france à anses d'arlet
akkas pilote visite est vraiment en
bateau c'était plus simple et du coup on
aurait loué la voiture qu une semaine
donc la deuxième semaine des vacances au
lieu de quinze jours donc côté financier
aussi bas ça nous coûte un peu plus cher
aussi de louer la voiture 15 jours et je
m'étais posé la question pour à la foire
de france parce que je voulais faire le
marché et la voilà je savais pas si
aujourd'hui ça marche et en fait ça
fonctionne toujours pas j'ai pas de
voiture donc du coup soit j'arrive à
faire du stop pour bien jusqu'ici et
prendre la navette soit je fais du stop
jusqu'à fort de france mais je suis
aussi dépendante de sa donc look on
verra ce matin les grévistes des
vedettes tropicales ont rejoint ceux de
la sotra homme à la gare routière de
petit manoir
l'occasion de faire le point sur la
grève générale qui concerne plusieurs
entreprises de l'île et rappeler leurs
revendications
l'effectivité des salaires l'équité
problème d'équité au niveau des
plannings la mise en place des
billetteries prévu depuis juillet 2010
est de son côté la direction dit n'avoir
obtenu aucune revendication écrite et
contestent de nombreux points comme par
exemple la mise en place des bornes de
billetterie
concernant la mise en place des bornes
un monsieur domaine public maritime ça a
pris du temps d'avant les autorisations
aux 3 il est à fort-de-france et à
case-pilote alimentation seul site il ya
si beau deuxièmement il faut raccorder
ces bornes ou isolées tri aujourd'hui
toutes nos bonnes se raccorder sur celle
de fort de france où il ya un problème
la preuve nous avons payé depuis mars
2018 et ne rencontre aucun problème
entre les différents intervenants sur le
site au niveau du paiement des jours de
grève
non les jours de grève ne sont pas payés
vers le fil d'apple sont déjà partis
aujourd'hui par la poste avec les
chèques et les seniors se sont arrêtés
au diffuseur en haute saison
les vedettes tropicale transporte
environ 2000 à 2500 passagers par jour
abonnés et touristes confondus qui
attendent la fin du conflit